47% des travailleurs presque un
travailleur sur deux n'a pas de régime
de retraite oui il faut transformer les
régimes municipaux notamment
mais que faire de tous ceux et de toutes
celles qui n'ont rien pour la retraite
tous calculs sur les régimes de retraite
bonjour cette semaine l'avenir des
régimes de retraite d'une part on dit
que les travailleurs et les retraités
doivent assumer une plus grande charge
du financement de régime mais d'un autre
côté d'autre part la moitié des
québécois n'ont pas de régime de
retraite et le gouvernement fédéral ne
veut pas bonifier les rendre publiques
on en parle avec liza frulla pierre
paquette à la place de rémy trudel cette
semaine et pierre fortin associé chez
raymond chabot grant thornton
spécialistes du secteur municipal
comptable une calculatrice pour vous ont
besoin
bonjour bonjour à vous deux merci encore
d'être avec nous pour cette belle
émission tous calculs
la première question est l etat lisa et
à pierre est ce que vous trouvez qu'un
déséquilibre trop marquée en ce moment
en ceux qui ont des régimes de retraites
et des régimes assez généreux et ceux
qui n'en ont pas c'est à dire un
québécois sur deux parce qu'avec le
vieillissement de la population
effectivement il ya un côté très
inquiétant et malgré que nous au québec
on à la riche des rangs
ce qu'ils ont pas en ontario parce qu'on
s'aperçoit que le mail avec la campagne
électorale qui s'engendre qui
s'enclenche en ontario on s'aperçoit
aussi que la première ministre quand on
wind et on le voit d'aucun devaient
parler aussi de la retraite preuvre par
la retraite à cause du vieillissement de
la population et qu un moment donné il
va falloir penser et pensée aussi pour
le futur là aujourd'hui on va gérer le
présent
excepté que il va falloir maintenant
penser à être beaucoup plus prudent
pour ceux qui s'en viennent les autres
quand même penser aussi que il va y
avoir deux points 3 en 1930 en 2030 2.3
travailleurs pour un retraité
alors
ça c'est vraiment vraiment disait
maintenant l'avenir et penser est ce
qu'il me double crise
pierre paquette c'est dur la clique des
régimes de retraite actuel qu'il faut
financer
oui ceux qui en ont pas mais pourquoi
généraliser non plus le lien il ya un
problème particulier dans le secteur
particulier municipal quelques grosses
entreprises mais hydro québec vient de
renouer avec les surplus au plan de sa
la valeur actuarielle de son régime de
retraite aux états en ontario aussi eu
des améliorations à air canada
donc faut faire attention au faux pas
mais tous les régimes de prestations
déterminées dans le même bateau moi je
pense que ce qui serait normal ce serait
con et trois piliers pour préparer la
retraite
les régimes publics des régimes
complémentaires il y en a plusieurs
le titre possible et les banques privées
alors ce qui est anormal c'est de pas
avoir de pas pouvoir compter sur un
troisième pilier qui le régime
complémentaire au régime public et allez
pas me priver
parlons des régimes de retraite qui sont
existants donc il ya beaucoup de gens
dans le secteur public qui ont des
régimes de retraite on compare on pense
beaucoup aux fonctionnaires bien sûr
qu'ils ont des régimes de retraite ça
c'est clair
mais la moitié des québécois n'ont pas
de régime de retraite est ce que vous
trouvez qu'on vit dans un système à deux
vitesses
mais c'est bien parce ce moment où on a
35 % des travailleurs du québec un
régime à prestations déterminées donc
qui ont une grande gagnante si et de
l'open de notre portion de population on
en a 50 % qui ont trop de régimes de
retraite dont promotionnelle à 3 à trois
niveaux
c'est ce que on est dans un système à
deux vitesses le risque d'une part est
assumée par soit l'état soit les grandes
entreprises que les régimes à
prestations déterminées et d'un autre
part le risque d'assumer entièrement
pour ceux qui en europe à l'épargnant
elle contribuera mais on a les traits
seulement on a l'impression qu'il ya une
classe de favoriser il ya les favorisés
et les noms favorisés est-ce qu'on a
raison de penser que de trop d'accords
cassés négocié c'est ces régimes là
s'est comptée comme des rémunérations
alors c'est du salaire crier différer
dans le temps
et c'est le fruit de la négociation
alors parfois on va bonifier le régime
de retraite pour éviter une augmentation
salariale immédiate en fait il ya toutes
sortes de circonstances mais ça a été
négocié et ça fait partie de la
rémunération la dtm et dans le secteur
public si l'ensemble des québécois qui
paient oui mais la preuve étant que
quand gouvernance qui avait comparé les
salaires des employés de l'état aux
salaires du secteur privé y inclus ces
avantages la et les difficultés que
connaît actuellement un régime public je
parle pour pas nécessairement là encore
une fois je propose monde municipal jeu
pas vraiment de la fonction publique
québécoise
le réseau public parapublic c'est le
fait quelques relances québec a promis
sa part pendant longtemps ça c'est 2
milliards de livres de déficit
d'abord quand j'entends ça par ce médium
est l'un d'eux je m'excuse mais ils ont
choisi certains ont choisi de travailler
dans la fonction publique ont choisi de
travailler en espagne et de devenir
fonctionnaires y en a d'autres ont
choisi autre chose et en ayant choisi
d'être policiers sénégalais ce qu il y
en a d'autres ont choisi autre chose
le cas qu'ils arrivent à la fin pour
prendre leur retraite ont fait bagarre
devant lui et charles supplie pas changé
mais je m'excuse mais c'est parce que
t'as pas choisi la même chose dans ton
cheminement est différente et
coresponsable de nos choix deuxième
police et 550 milles de l'état ou ska
pierre dit c'est que eux m 50 50 pages
pourquoi de la excuse je parle pas leur
vendre nos municipalités mais les grains
les grandes fonctions publiques
québécoises 1 sur les 559 le partage à
50 50
le problème c'est que la capitalisation
l'état on n'a pas capitalisé à 1973
quand ils ont décidé d'un veau des
régimes de retraite ont commencé à
capter les années 90 ans que j'ai raison
pourtant alors là on se retrouve avec un
difficile
fortin en fait les deux et deux éléments
des éléments comme madame claudine mendy
qui provient de décisions qui ont été
prises soient les congés de cotisation
soit des partages qui tape à 50 50 que
maintenant on dit avec l'évolution de la
conjoncture économique la conjoncture
démographique
on doit rétablir cet équilibre à 50 50
l'autre élément volet conjoncturel et
structurel la démographie la population
et
plus en plus vieillissant et villes de
plus en plus longuement donc on doit
payer pendant plus longtemps et d'un
autre côté la durée de vie active des
gens on voir aux études plus longtemps
et on prend notre retraite plus tôt
alors là on est on est beaux tableaux
pour illustrer ce que vous venez dire
pierre forte on va regarder ça derrière
moi dans le grand mur le premier tableau
qui va nous montrer un petit peu le le
portrait de la situation je vous dirai
dans l'ensemble du québec travailleurs
du québec ça c'était dans le rapport
d'amour qui a été publiée au mois
d'avril 2013 3 millions neuf cent
cinquante quatre mille travailleurs il y
en a un petit peu plus aujourd'hui mon
pare de ses chefs là alors de ces
travailleurs à cotisations déterminées
4% donc c'est à dire que c'est un régime
où on sait combien on cotise mais on
sait pas exactement combien on va
toucher à la retraite à prestations
déterminées donc on connaît combien on
va toucher à la retraite 35 % des
travailleurs québécois 14% d'autres
types de régime et 47 % n'ont aucun
régime collectif c'est un problème ça
lorsqu'on expliqué en début de mission à
savoir qui en guise d'avoir dirigé
maggie vitesse parce qu'on a à perdre
pression déterminé que le risque est
d'en sur la fonction publique malgré les
décisions qui ont plus pris goût et de
l'autre côté c'est totalement l'épargné
et le deuxième tableau qu'on veut
montrer puis vous allez nous expliquer
pierre fortin c'est le tableau qui nous
montre clairement l'évolution de la
durée des retraites des canadiens de
1970 à 2010 en 1966 quarante et une
années d'activité quatorze ans de
retraite ont viré moins longtemps
la bonne nouvelle aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on vit plus longtemps on travaille
moins 39 ans d'activité et 23 ans de
retraite c'est clair ça c'est clair et
c'est çà çà çà çà veut dire que la
pression est lé là sur le système de
retraite actuel ce qu'on nomme
maintenant 39 ans a cumulé 23 ans de
grâce à des ressources qu'on avait 41
après 2014 en grève des cheminots avec
des tours de la main qui ont diminué au
fil du temps parce que les obligations
des pensions ce qu'apple en 1981 il
était autour de 15%
maintenant on a trois pour cent du tour
e alors est ce que régis labeaume est ce
que denis coderre
et est-ce que de façon générale on a
raison de dire en regardant cela qu'il
ya urgence d'agir qu'il faut agir il
faut renégocier les régimes de retraite
avec les employés municipaux par exemple
et l'on voit la menace pas tort se
rappelle juste avant l'élection
suppression entre autres de monsieur la
bombe et coderre la ministre a déposé le
projet de loi 78 projets de loi pour
permettre aux municipalités de de revoir
enfin l'ensemble de la fiscalité de la
physique en fait des régimes de la tête
je me retrouve alors là on s'est aperçu
aussi que cette semaine avec la
rencontre avec le premier ministre et le
ministre des affaires municipales
monsieur moreau on va redéposer le
projet de loi et on a promis que c'était
le projet de loi était pourrait être pas
assez pour fin décembre 2004 ce qui est
intéressant est que le voile parce que
pour quelqu'un ça rate elle sait que ça
ne touchait que les régimes qui était en
difficulté
les jeunes de prestations déterminées
qui en discute et non ce qu'ils
s'arrangent bill comme celui la société
de transport de montréal qui est plus
que quand surplus ou et hydro ou
ailleurs ils sont pas touchés par la loi
le deuxième chose c'est que la
capitalisation était fixé à 95 85 % du
du régime et sas avait été accueillie
favorablement par à peu près tout le
monde alors j'espère que le gouvernement
va pas réinventer de boutoir a su
rebondir à 85 % c'est-à-dire pour chaque
dollar d'engagement de retraite qu'il
faut verser il ya 85 scène que prévu en
quelque sorte la qui est de côté en
quelque sorte est-ce que décrivez-nous
le problème dans les régimes de retraite
municipaux combier de régimes de
retraite municipaux sont
sous-capitalisées c'est quoi le problème
environ 50% des régimes à prestations
déterminées au québec qui sont dans une
situation précaire
69e rapport d'amour précaire d'une part
donc qui est en accusant un déficit en
dessous de 80 du pilat
en hausse outre 85% campagne donc ça
c'est un premier élément
l'autre élément sur le prêt d'un autre
angle c'est maintenant à la ville de
montréal on parle de 10 % du budget de
la ville qui est pour certains éléments
lors des régimes de retraite alors qu'il
ya d'autres préoccupations donc on prend
souvent sur l'un des régimes de retraite
mais sur le brillant sur la capacité de
payer du citoyen ou l'ensemble est la
portion du budget de l'auvent de la rue
saint avold sur les jeunes mariés
on parle de 8 % québec 10 % à montréal
de là cette urgence d'âgés et de la
pression que les deux mêmes sauf qu'en
même temps faut voir d'abord ça a été
négocié dans le temps jean paul l'allier
qui a été maire de québec
c'est un ancien ministre de la fonction
publique et certainement pour ses
premiers à genoux qui à plat ventre
devant les syndicats c'est qu'à l'époque
la conjoncture des négociations la
gestion des ressources humaines au fait
qu'il ya des choix qui ont été faits
alors maintenant on peut pour lire le
livre à l'envers et entre autres des
problèmes qui avaient c'est que dès
qu'il veut 10% plus et plus de surplus à
la caisse on devait à ce moment leur
soit bonifier le régime soit encore
donner des congés de cotisation et c'est
ce qu'on a vécu des années 90 wallace a
été revu mais c'est une responsabilité
aussi de l'état du gouvernement des
parlementaires des législateurs mais
n'avoir pas permis et c'était pour
éviter entre autres que les entreprises
privées mettent trop d'argent dans les
caisses pour éviter de gonfler leur
revient vous avez parlé lisa de cette
rencontre entre monsieur moreau monsieur
couillard monsieur labeaume monsieur
coderre a eu lieu un peu plus tôt cette
semaine les maires coderre et labeaume
sont sortis à cette bonne humeur
on les a connus la question c'est juste
une question de temps et déchets ainsi
tout le monde la même volonté de faire
soit le plus rapidement possible
et les discussions qu'on a eues sur
l'échéancier a de quoi nous soulager
nous conforte dans l'idée que devant la
main veut vraiment aller aussi vite
qu'on pouvait l'espérer
alors le gouvernement veut aller vite et
est ce que le gouvernement est en train
de pencher en faveur des municipalités
de donner plus de pouvoir aux
municipalités de décréter en quelque
sorte le partage des régimes de retraite
et le partage surtout des déficits des
régimes de retraite et est-ce qu'il faut
persuader hoffbeck pas même à six sont
bonnes même plus et de l'eau c'est parce
qu'il semble que là ça penche en leur
faveur
seule chose deuxièmement est ce qu'il
faut faire ça je pense qu'il faut le
faire mais avec le respect puis de toute
façon tout le monde est d'accord mais
j'ai entendu l'hymne est aussi visée
avec le respect de leurs travailleurs
aussi parce que les syndicats sont
sortis puis on fait une loi là est un
instinct nous on veut négocier alors
dans la loi si on revient à la loi au
projet de loi 78 par exemple régimes de
retraite y avait une provision dans ses
toiles ocre pour négociations c'est on
disait entendez vous sinon un
négociateur et apprécions la voix la
commission des relations de travail
il fallait il faut avoir des mécanismes
pour que sa surface du mieux possible et
je dirais moi dans une paix sociale 6
heures c'est là qu'on peut s'inquiéter
de voir le sourire de monsieur gaudin de
la banque puisque dans le projet doit
maintenant à malte et en prévoyant une
âme négociations puis en suisse étaient
les leurs le conseil des relations de
travail qui prenaient de 12,6 en main
pour une médiation prévention tranché 6
et les municipalités
là ça devient ridicule parce que deux
partis qui négocient dont une qui sait
qu'au bout du compte c'est elle qui vont
imposer le règlement sa politique le
gouvernement libéral n'avait pas
d'enfant c'est drôle lisa et pierre
parceque la semaine dernière quand on
s'est laissé on disait mon dieu le ton
et bord entre le gouvernement et les
syndicats
ça change mais j'avais fait une
stratégie on en parle mais monsieur
fortin et moi du bon policier du mauvais
policiers de cobb smith et martin les
moteurs et
mais je sais qu'il ya eu des rencontres
aussi entre le ministre des finances et
les centrales syndicales cette semaine
et donc s'ils se sont rencontrés c'est
qu'ils ont ouvert un espace pour
dialoguer mais parfait donc la
négociation est déjà très important
c'est que tout le monde soit conscient
de ce que vous dites monsieur fortin
c'est à dire que le dise pour ça que ça
coûte
les régimes de retraite à la ville de
montréal par exemple c'est 10 % de moins
que l'on peut utiliser beaucoup plus
utilisés de façon possible même pour les
travailleurs là et que donc si tout le
monde est partie prenante dans ce pour
cela la négociation exploiter merci pour
vos tableaux merci pour vos choix vos
explications monsieur fortin on vous
libère mais vous de on vous garde parce
que justement vous avez prononcé le nom
de martin coiteux martin coiteux qui a
laissé entendre lui cette semaine que
les salaires des employés pourraient
être liés à la productivité avec moment
on mesure la productivité d'un monde de
l'éducation par exemple on en parle dans
un instant
on a un déficit qui est très élevée on
doit éliminer
on reprend d'édition du c'est ce qu'on
doit faire ce serait gêné moi comme
ministre me semble de demander aux gens
d'augmenter leur productivité alors que
ça fait des années qu'on pressent le
citron
on demande toujours plus aux gens voilà
c'est ça je vous parlais de changement
ton tantôt le sait la suite d'abord de
tous calculs avec les africa et pierre
paquette
on parle de salaires et de productivité
et même de la productivité du secteur de
l'administration publique monsieur quoi
te le dis la rémunération les salaires
pourraient peut-être suivre la
productivité ça se fait juste une bonne
idée qu'est ce que vous en pensez
moi je pense qu'on va perdre énormément
de temps à négocier ce qui est la
productivité du secteur public
ça veut pas dire que on doit pas
travailler à l'améliorer constamment
mais comment mesurer sa dans la santé ça
veut dire un bain de moins par mois
ça veut dire cinq élèves de plus dans
les classes parce que sinon c'est avec
des humains là que l'appui passer ça et
parce que la productivité c'est la
valeur de ce qu'ont fait par heure
travaillée donc la valeur de ce qu'on
fait c'est que ce produit là au bout le
résultat doit être un peu plus gros à
chaque heure de travail est déjà si vous
avez dans un hôpital voyez que les
parents sont mis à contribution
les bénévoles sont mis à contribution
c'est du travail qui se faisait
autrefois par des employés de l'état et
donc moi j'ai beaucoup de misère à voir
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont être capables de
faire à moins encore une fois de se
délester des services qui sont donnés
absolument par des taux alors des beaux
arts déco dont la caisse qui veut faire
lâcher parce que encore une fois comment
qualifie la cie justement la valeur la
valeur par rapport au dollar
mais je me dis aussi on s'est dit
beaucoup aussi que c'était toute la face
ont travaillé ce qu'on demande aux
employés est ce que ça a du bon sens ou
non donner un exemple le cabaret est
sorti aujourd'hui puis à la docteure
barré assez fort at that on va prendre
des décisions vous l'excès on a vécu
très longtemps puisque voulait
l'entendre les coûts tout de suite quand
on prend
des directions vous allez avoir un choix
ou bien vous allez dans la direction
ou bien vous y allez pas il s'y voyait
les porcs mais là il va y avoir des
conséquences
je sais aujourd'hui vous pourriez réagir
en disant on va faire de l'obstruction
ce pas une bonne idée
il y en a des solutions mais le jour où
moi je trouve une solution
il va falloir que les résultats soient
nos douze lots céline girard les
médecins mais les médecins ils vont se
regarder la même affaire qu'on est dans
l'essai dans l'affrontement bassée mais
j'ai tout à fait mais il ya une chose
intéressante dit c'est qu'on va trouver
des solutions parfait mais ça on trouve
des solutions
c'est quoi les solutions pesos 2 va
falloir surveiller est-ce que c'est
moins de moins de paperasserie combien
de fois dans le réseau de la santé et d
écouter vélo - les agences hoyano
combien par le directeur de poule puis
vont vous dire les agents c'est
peut-être vraiment un palier trop loin
est ce que vous pourriez s'il vous plaît
nous donner les directives de nous
autres on voit administrer alvin ou des
couches sur nos sur nos épaules puis oh
oui on va être plus productifs pee wee
on a été efficace justement comme les
invités d'un secteur public c'est que ça
nécessite du travail s'était tu sais que
du contrôle et cd4 de plus alors depuis
2003 dans le secteur de la santé il ya
23 % de cadres de plus alors du côté des
syndiqués e édition du gras à couper le
commencer par couper l'encadrement puis
laissez nous plus d'autonomie
alors ça va ça va susciter un bon débat
ceci monsieur bart a dit qu'il faut
appliquer des solutions
l'une des choses que réjean hébert
m'avait raconté ce qu'il y avait plein
de règlement que le gouvernement de
monsieur charest va passer dans le
secteur de la santé qui n'étaient pas
appliquées et que le ministère ne
faisait pas appliqué soit par laxisme ou
indifférence ou que sais je donne juste
un exemple le stationnement dans les
des hôpitaux de longue durée il était
supposé payant et puis dans la plupart
des institutions il n'était pas payant
c'est monsieur hébert et de glace parce
que je crois que le rendu payant sous
une forme de tarification une
tarification oui c'est pour des gens qui
viennent de l'extérieur
et puis je trouve un peu bizarre que
monsieur bart est finalement critique
indirectement son ancien collègue
selah sue l'éliminer de la santé et le
sylvie qui quels portefeuilles justement
une portefeuille monsieur quoi tu l'as à
la santé c'est monsieur barrette qui là
est ce que quand c'est quoi 60 65 % des
dépenses et celles sur la santé
l'éducation la santé mais c'est des
salaires c'est la rémunération à quelque
sorte
est ce que on n'a pas le choix d'aller
jouer justement sur la rémunération
quand on regarde au fil au fil du temps
puis je vois que vous demandez juste de
recul un petit peu parce qu'on va sortir
notre grand tableau pour regarder un peu
la rémunération de l'administration
québécoise des salaires la hausse prévue
2010 0.50 8.5 1,8 et 2% en 2014
jeudi quand on prend l'inflation ben là
on se rend compte qu'en 2010 après
inflation c'était une baisse en 2011
2012 également 2013 une hausse qui on
prévoit une petite hausse après
l'inflation au cours de l'année 2014 on
voit que les salaires de
l'administration publique québécoise
sont sous pression
déjà tout à fait mais ce qu'il faut
aller plus loin mais c'est ce que l'on
est ici là on dit qu'un gel on vient
dont on a parlé d'un gel de la prochaine
négocié en 2014 et 12.5 ce jeudi 8 après
ce stage est donc encore une fois cette
colonne là aussi la cette colonne aussi
vauvert bip va probablement variés même
dalle à la haye la négative dans une
fois qu'on a dit ça il va avoir de
l'attrition il va y avoir des façons de
faire
quand on parle de productivité pour moi
la valeur c'est de regarder les façons
de faire faciliter l'utilisation des
nouvelles technologies sont ne pas
parler beaucoup et je vais vous dire
honnêtement là pour vous dire que le
gouvernement est encore c'est un
euphémisme
alors c'est tout seul va falloir
regarder et non pas juste l'individu
holmes mais qu'est ce que tu lui donnes
pour qu'ils soient plus performants et
l'autre problème c'est vous l'avez
mentionné hier déjà il ya un retard de
la rémunération globale incluant les
régimes de retraite des employés de
l'état d'à peu près 8 à 10% des parlant
d'un salarié en dehors de la misère à
recruter là avec le vieillissement de la
population il va avoir moins de le
bassin mais devra être moins aujourd'hui
crois qu'on va inciter les gens à
travailler plus longtemps puis
probablement il y en a beaucoup qui vont
être intéressés à le faire parce qu'ils
sont plus en forme mais il y aura quand
même pour le secteur public un défi de
recrutement auprès de la jeunesse alors
défi de recrutement défi dans la
population active parce que beaucoup de
gens qui avec le vieillissement de la
population qui sortent de la population
active
les pressions sur la rémunération de la
fonction publique
les pressions sur les régimes de
retraite en 2014 on est où là
qu'est ce qui est en train d'arriver là
pour qu'on on s'en charge à pradines
comme ça moi je pense que je pense
qu'avec les syndics ans ensemble
il faut absolument changer de paradigme
d'abord évaluer la situation mais paul
enjolivé riez mais on regarde la
situation telle qu'elle est là et on
parlais tantôt de se projeter dans le
futur
puis ensuite de se dire maintenant
comment on peut faire pour travailler et
travailler mieux et je reviens après ça
à l'utilisation des outils qu'on n'avait
pas avant qu'on a actuellement grâce à
la nouvelle technologie le sauve veut
pas vouloir un éternel le grand défi du
québec c'est de renouer avec la
croissance économique
et puis le développement économique et
puis cc c'est la priorité
le grand nom doit avoir parce qu'avec
des taux croissance autour de 1 %
c'est évident qu'on va avoir des
problèmes au niveau des finances
publiques ont tous ces problèmes là donc
il faut avoir de la croissance pour être
capable d'aller chercher des revenus qui
est capable de contrôler les dépenses on
en a parlé la semaine dernière mais ils
ont remporté 2 1 josé la croissance des
revenus et une chose on essaie de la
ponte des lots on peut jouer c'est sur
les dépenses oui gouvernement devait
agir sur les dépôts daily mail c'est
l'on n'est pas loin d'atteindre les
limites à 2%
c'est à peu près le niveau de
l'inflation celi la croissance des
dépenses oui alors quand
n'augmente les dépenses 2 % ça veut dire
qu'on augmente au rythme de mais
globalement on augmente au rythme du
coût de la vie donc on n'a pas plus
d'argent pour payer plus de monde ou
plus d'équipements ou mais ça veut dire
de faire aussi certains investissements
l'onu une bonne nouvelle qui dort au
québec au roi des profils des profits
records c'est bon c'est bon pour le
gouvernement mais il va y avoir aussi
mais ce qui m'inquiète touche au moins
les mines et des finances on les a
pratiqué la pile et menez présent aussi
alors c'est la seule de dieu la coupe
mais il faut aussi contrôler les
dépenses mais pense à certains
investissements je vais très bien merci
d'abord merci beaucoup de plaisir de
vous retrouver votre mission si vous
avez des commentaires à la maison calcul
à commercial radio canada.ca donc vous
n'hésitez pas à nous écrire et je vous
mentionne que notre invité à rdi
économie ce soir c'est carlos leitao
justement d'économiste en chef de la
laurentienne un ministre des finances
quel est son parcours et quels sont ses
objectifs
notre invité à 18h30 à plus tard